her JP and Beth hailer are from Oregon
Missouri my folks brought us up to kind
of conserve our money to be responsible
with money that kind of sank in for a
while until I started going out and
actually making money
popular opinion was always there that
while you're always going to have a car
payment and you know you're gonna have a
house payment and those are things
they're just part of life
we both had good jobs for our age we
were making a lot of money and had
nothing to show for it
she was listen to the radio one day and
her Dave Ramsey on the radio who's this
crazy guy and I think that was that
didn't you actually say that instead
that's crazy like yeah yeah you decide
I'm getting out of debt why because all
my money goes out in payments I don't
have any money you live impulse to
impulse thank God it's Friday - oh god
it's money I know I used to do this
stuff but you know what I put myself in
a position that those things could
happen my folks bought us a copy of
financial piece and we started going
through it and oh I don't know how how
far we into it a couple months into it
and found out that Harley had cancer it
put everything on hold we would go
charge the things that we need he had no
backup plan no emergency fund no nothing
so we focused on her and figuring out
what we had to do to help her to be well
again so I think the turning point for
us was when she's going to the grocery
store and she's using a credit card to
buy basic necessities after we knew that
she was on maintenance and thanks for
going really well
and just took off from there we had
sixty four thousand dollars worth of
consumer debt and it was staggering
going back through FPU was really a
catalyst to help us push forward and
really drive and get it done this isn't
just a shameless plug for days we
actually do play this game and it
reinforces what we're trying to teach
them in life so the kids have learned
early on that if they they do a certain
chore they get a little bit of money for
here for their great place to go oh when
you're broke don't work we had a small
fire outside the house right here and it
took this whole wall
I had cleaned out the ash from the
fireplace and set it to let it cool and
then a day later set it outside the door
and the wind picked up and now I'm
forever teased as the person who tried
to burn down our house we had a original
contract was with one lender they sold
our loan we had no new contract it's
just hey you make your payments to us
now but we didn't know what to expect
from them until this fire happened JP
called him and said we have a contractor
we have to pay what are we supposed to
do and they gave us the runaround it was
ridiculous so we just lumped all of our
money with what they were gonna pay out
for this little fire and hey often know
it's our house and we're saving for
another car now to replace Clifford
he'll be retired to only the stuff
hauler I was gone I was out of town for
a while
and I got a phone call that said hey we
just went in for a checkup
everything's great I don't have labs yet
but hardly looking feeling great all
this and that
the following Monday her nurse
practitioner called and said hey we were
looking her at Harley's labs and I hate
to tell you this on the phone but we're
pretty sure that the Leukemia is back
having that emergency fund was so far
grander than and taken a credit card and
charged me everything on a credit card
we knew that our financial life was
going to be okay two rounds of enough
cancer two rounds of chemotherapy a
house fire it seems insurmountable it
can be done if you just focus and do
what Dave teaches our debt free Scream
was on Monday and so the day before
Sunday was her very last chemo we're
very blessed normal kid again yeah she's
a normal kid again a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars paid off in six years
in one month and we're gonna be
cancer-free
seventy-five thousand dollar income
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one weird